es geht das ist liebe euch apropos
kukksi also ich muss diese scheiß genug
zurücksenden
meine damen und herren und herzlich
willkommen ja heute zu einem neuen video
auf meinem plan jetzt bereits zum 7
deswegen sitzen was wirklich
geschmackssorten der pizza sein da hat
sich unter dem letzten video jeder frage
weil ich einfach noch nicht gesagt habe
gab heute der dichten also erstmal ein
bisschen kontext zu schaffen ich bin
riesiger pizza fan diesem pool dann gibt
es meinem shop dieser windows server
das steht sogar ein leichtes da drauf
ich weiß nicht ich weiß nämlich der
größte pizza heil der welt bin aber ich
esse halt unglaublich gerne wenn ich in
der neustadt kommen ich denke direktor
kate nicht was sie eben die tradition
sind das ist die kultur was ich hier was
ist hier immobilie macht bleibt etwa
direkter als in madrid war auch direkt
pizza essen gegangen also ja genau davon
übrigens auch erst mal ganz kurz unter
die letzten videos haben einige leute
geschrieben dass sie von dem ganzen hin
und her zu machen dass sie davon
schwindelig werden also deswegen wir
werden versuchen da ein bisschen
rücksicht auf euch zu nehmen ist ein
großer moment ich sage euch was das für
eine pizza wird wir sagen ich habe alle
meine freunde
wir sehen schauen wir haben hier vier
kartons die werde ich euch gleich auch
komplett zeigen den karton habe ich nun
endlich hier und bei der dame hatte ich
natürlich auch zeigen was passiert für
pizzen sind denn dass sie waren alle
skizzen die wir getestet haben in den
letzten wochen monaten einfach
herauszufinden was möchte ich wirklich
für die pizza haben was schmeckt am
besten
wir haben uns gedacht das gibt jetzt
noch nicht im tiefkühlregal in
deutschland was könnte man eben mal
zimmer im hilchenbacher machen was es so
noch nicht gehabt bei meinem
virtualnights hängt halt immer okay wir
müssen jedes mal bei jedem etwas machen
was es so noch nicht in meinem shop
karte hatten wir beispielsweise kissen
haben oder eingepackt
die jeansjacke reingepasst lektor jacke
wir haben immer verschiedene sachen
reingepackt die sony mal im shop hat er
deswegen habe ich jetzt sagt wir müssen
etwas machen was ist nicht überall
mussten noch nicht gab
sondern was es vielleicht allgemein
weltweit noch nie im tiefkühlregal zu
kaufen bedenkt man sich hier erst mal
okay davon ganz normal mit witzen
das sind auch ganz normale plätzen wenn
unser erster gedanke war denn man kann
eine pizza rustica an haben wir unter
anderem tolle getestet wir haben salami
ist ich bin dabei ehrlich gesagt ein
riesiger salami fällen saarlandes hat ja
meist vergessen wir dass gesagt wird
nicht eine salami raus weil ich selber
einfach nicht so gern esse und da hast
du kapitza ist mussten wir natürlich
auch schmecken der pflege
da haben wir uns für die lukas am 2
kommt nichts anderes infrage halt eine
pizza prosciutto denkt man sich erstmal
ist nix drin
ich werde euch noch nicht genau die
pizza zeigen denn leute mit pizza frust
so wie ich zu beginn gesagt habe so
etwas werden was es noch nie im
tiefkühlregal gar eine pizza prosciutto
kennt jeder
die gibt es im tiefkühlregal gibt es
genug andere unternehmen die tolle
spitzenkultur pizza prosciutto ihr wisst
was ich meine es wird keine normale
pizza prosciutto ganz kurze info eben
noch an alle vegetarier die jetzt
eventuell traurig so dass di luca pizza
zwar nicht vegetarisch ist wir haben bei
der herstellung extra den hinterschinken
am ende
lose auf den käse gelegt das heißt ihr
könnt sogar vom bakken sagen hey ich
will keinen schinken dann hebt er den
einfach runter und habe dann quasi eine
vegetarische pizza margarita ich werde
euch noch nicht genau sagen was es für
eine pizza sein wird und liefern sie
sich von anderen pizza prosciutto
unterscheiden wird aber ihr wisst es auf
jeden fall schon mal es wird eine pizza
belegt mit käse mit tomatensoße mit
hinterschinken sein sowie der karton auf
dem roller wird nicht zerrissen sein
so wird er außerdem keine sitzen drinnen
also ich weiß nicht warum ich überhaupt
allem tiefgläubiger dann hab ich möchte
diese pizza bis jetzt noch nicht zeigen
hier sind nämlich bin ich ganz ehrlich
sind vorsichtig weil das eine idee ist
dies wirklich so noch nicht als pizza im
tief gläubiger gleich jetzt niemand nach
sieben uns zuvor abkommen oder so haben
zehn tage vor dem launch teplitzer am 15
10 werde ich ein video auf dem kanal
opladen wo ich euch zum ersten mal die
pins zeige sie zum ersten mal hier
zusammen vor der kamera auf meinem
youtube kanal da habt ihr dann alle
informationen breite verfügbarkeit et
cetera et also leute am 13 10 kommt das
video wo ich die pizza zum erstmals zwei
tage später am 15 10 kommt die pizza
deutschland weiter alle rede und edeka
märkte alte tragt euch diese beiden
daten in eurem kalender einem 13 sehen
wenn ihr wissen wollt wie die pilze aus
sehen wir dann am 15 10 kommen sie raus
sonst nicht hat sie noch der stadt jetzt
auch bett ich bin mega mega mega trucks
gespannt es ist das riesige projekt was
ich je angegangen wenn du auf meinem
youtube-kanal letzte besser war schon
krass aber jetzt dass das wird heftig
und läufer von 15 19 auch passieren wird
ist nicht nur dass meine pizza einfach
so raus kommen sondern es wird auch noch
eine mega kraft video moment kann er
kommen und ich haben uns überlegt was
wir am 15.10 zum launch weder pitts
seinem revier in köln machen wollen mal
gucken wie das alles so hinkriegen wie
es geplant haben als mit kras freude
[Musik]